[Music]
after months of travel you've arrived at
duo Nia home to the famous temple that's
the destination of your pilgrimage
entering from the northwest you pass
through the city gates and the Welcome
Center where you're given a map and a
brochure the map reveals that the town
consists of 16 blocks formed by five
streets that run west to east
intersecting five more that run north to
south you're standing on the
northernmost street facing east with the
two blocks containing the gate and the
Welcome Center behind you the temples
only entrance lies at the very southeast
corner it's not a long walk but there's
a problem as you learn from the brochure
duo Nia imposes a unique tax on all
visitors which must be paid when they
arrive at their destination within the
city the tax begins at zero increases by
two silver for every block you walk east
and doubles for every block you walk
south however a recent reform to make
the tax fairer halves your total bill
for every block you walk north and
subtracts two silver for every block you
walk west just passing through the gate
and the Welcome Center means you already
owe four silver as a pilgrim you carry
no money and have no way of earning any
what's more the rules of your pilgrimage
forbid you from walking over any stretch
of ground more than once during your
journey though you can cross your own
path can you figure out a way to reach
the temple without owing any tax or
walking the same block twice in any
direction
you look at the map to consider your
options walking towards the temple
always increases the tax and walking
away decreases it so it seems like you
can never reach it without owing silver
but what happens when you walk around a
single block if you start out owing for
silver and go clockwise starting east
your tax bill becomes six then 12 then
ten then five if you looped again you'd
oh seven fourteen twelve and six it
seems that each clockwise loop leaves
you owing one extra silver what about a
counterclockwise loop then starting
going for again and going south first
your bill changes to eight ten five and
three looping again you'd owe six eight
four and two each counterclockwise loop
actually earns you one silver that's
because any tax doubled plus two halved
and minus two always ends up one smaller
than it started the key here is that
while the different taxes for opposite
directions may seem to balance each
other out the order in which they're
applied makes a huge difference
you start off owing four silver so for
counterclockwise loops would get you
down to zero unfortunately it's not that
simple since you can't walk the same
block twice but there's another way to
reduce your bill walking one large
counterclockwise loop through the city
from your starting position walk three
blocks south you need to leave the
southernmost street clear for the final
stretch so continuing counterclockwise
means going east walk two blocks to the
eastern wall and you owe a whopping
thirty six silver
but now you can start reducing your bill
three blocks north and one block west
cuts it to two point five you can't go
west from there that would leave you
with no way out so you go one block
south and the remaining three blocks
west leaving you with a debt of negative
one silver and since doubling a negative
number still gives you a negative number
walking the three blocks to the south
wall means the city owes you eight
fortunately that's exactly enough to get
you through the final blocks to the
temple as you enter you realize what
you've learned from your pilgrimage
sometimes an indirect route is the best
way to reach your destination if you
enjoy our riddles we think you'll love
the mind-boggling brain-teasing book the
number devil and thanks to our partners
at Picador you can get a copy of this
bestseller at a major discount for a
limited time check the comments section
or visit ed ted.com
slash books to learn more